I mean Google of Rod is,
you know,
just,
just recently rolled out,
um,
integration of,
of,
of realtime search and taking twitter
and,
and uh,
and status updates and putting that in
as one of the options within the web.
And obviously,
I mean,
not just not just google news,
but number different google properties
are all very curious and,
and,
and beating to think through what does
it mean for us?
How do we take advantage of that?
Um,
the way I,
I,
I think about it from,
from the new side of it,
is there,
there,
there are two aspects of it.
One is just the content itself.
I mean,
is there value in those tweets,
um,
uh,
or is it just,
is your sort of stream of information
that by itself just adds more noise to
it?
I think there's probably some of both.
And,
and that's,
that's a key part of what we try and do
is not just index the world's
information,
but also trying to organize it in some
level.
And so applying that to real time
information is very challenging.
Um,
so I think that that's one thing that
we're looking at the other part of is
just simply as another signal,
um,
of,
of a way of sort of picking up those
tweets about a certain topic or linking
to a certain story.
And is there a signal there that's
helpful for us and trying to pick up
information quicker.
We're trying to understand people's
preferences for certain sources are for
certain stories.
Um,
and so even if you never even surface
that information that we're,
that the real time tweets that are
there,
how can you leverage those,
uh,
those signals to do a better job of
presenting what you have on your own
site.
So I think both of those are areas that
we're actively looking at and trying to
figure out what's there.
But I'm sure we'll put something out
there and,
and maybe the first iteration will,
will,
will not work.
But that's,
that's I think,
um,
that's sort of the fun part about trying
to see how you can,
you can move forward and that's a makes,
makes things never dull.
I,
uh,
I don't know that in,
in just a few seconds or minutes or
probably hours,
I could explain what,
what,
uh,
what ways,
I think that the idea behind wave that
was,
was really interesting.
It was,
um,
if email didn't exist,
how would you communicate?
I think that was sort of the,
the,
the thought that a lot of the engineers,
um,
started with,
with,
with Google wave and really trying to
reimagine how people can communicate.
Um,
so it's part email,
it's part chat.
Uh,
it's part collaborative,
a collaborative documents.
Um,
so it's kind of all these roll together.
It's,
it's one of these things you need to
play around with it to,
to really even begin to try and
articulate what it is.
But that's one of the things is that
we've gotten a lot of interest from,
uh,
from journalists saying,
we think this is really fits well with
how we do our job.
And this is,
this is potentially a tool that we would
want to take advantage of,
um,
to tell stories,
to create that to,
um,
uh,
to create stories in a different way
than how we do it right now.
Even though it sort of fits with the way
we gather facts and information and
check and check sources,
um,
like how do we,
how do we sort of met,
migrate that to the web and make it a
much more of an,
of an open process.
Uh,
I think wave is still at the early
stages,
uh,
to try and figure out how it's going to
be used.
Um,
and journalism is just sort of one of
the things that we've,
we've seen a few different organizations
beginning to play around with don't know
what's,
what's ultimately gonna happen with,
with either wave,
the,
the larger discussion and also
specifically around around journalism.
Well,
it's certainly,
I mean,
the things that I talked about,
some of those trends in a,
about personalization,
um,
I mean that,
that's a big one for us.
Uh,
and the social nature of news,
uh,
to,
I mean,
I think those are things that,
um,
we,
we've had in bits and pieces,
but I don't think we've necessarily
gotten it all together.
Um,
it's tough.
I mean,
it's really hard when you talk about
personalization.
Even explicit personalization is not
easy to do well.
Uh,
and even if you get those,
those signals from users,
I'm trying to make sure that you get
them right and you interpret them in the
right way.
That's not an easy,
easy challenge to say nothing of.
The whole idea of implicit
personalization of just saying,
I come to the website,
you should know what I'm supposed to,
what would I want to read?
Um,
need to say that,
that,
that's even trickier.
So those are some of the things that
we're,
we're really thinking about.
And how do you,
how do you present that in a,
in a,
in a meaningful way to our users?
The balance,
because I think you don't want to have
the sort of echo chamber where you're
just getting that same news and
information from the same sources and
people that you've,
you've always gotten before.
Um,
I think you really want to try and have
that balance of,
of information that's personalized to
you.
Um,
but sort of,
uh,
at the same time you don't want to lose
the serendipity.
Um,
and also the important news and
information.
Let's say you need to know,
you may not want to read this,
but you need to know this.
Uh,
and so those are,
those are some of the things that I
think are,
um,
you know,
can be challenged on the web,
especially at the serendipity of it.
Like I was not searching for this.
I didn't know that I wanted to read
this,
but I'm glad that I found this on my,
uh,
on my site.
That's much easier to do right now in a
paper.
And he sort of pick it up.
You see the top stories of the day,
but then there,
here's an article the editors decided to
place on the front page because they
think it's important that they think
that it's interesting.
How do you introduce that online?
Um,
so those are,
those were some of the things you need
to balance with that,
you know,
the,
the really personalized news stream with
other things that just,
you know,
you may not know that they matter,
or rather you may not be thinking,
thinking them through to sort of say,
I want to search for it.
I want to subscribe to this feed.
But how do I get that in front of a,
it's important that,
that I get that in front of the user.